[Music]
do I believe in absolute truth I believe
an effective series let me tell you what
effective theory is an effective theory
says basically that I can if if I can't
measure something I don't have to worry
about it in the sense that for example
let's take newton's laws Newton's laws
work just fine but we know that
eventually we have to take into account
relativity if things were going really
fast
or we have to take into account quantum
mechanics if we were looking on really
tiny scales but for the scales we
observe you don't have to worry about
the fact that that a ball is made up of
atoms it's perfectly fine to think of it
as a ball with some mass because you
would never be able to measure the
effects of the atoms on the ball when
you're just throwing the ball so I guess
I believe that we there's a truth that
we know because it applies to the world
as we've seen it as we've measured it
that's not to say that there can't be
other underlying truths that you can see
if you can understand better if you
couldn't measure them better so I think
anything we know could be upset if you'd
look at regimes outside of the regime of
which we've studied them so but that's
not to say the truth is an absolute it's
absolute like the scales that we've seen
it but it's just not absolute in the
sense of applying at the most
fundamental
[Music]